[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh you guys are great welcome semistate
I play I'm very excited to talk about
everyone's favorite game series the sim
oh yeah I'm Julie hardy and today we're
giving you a guided tour of what's new
with the sims 4 plus a couple of fun
surprises so stay tuned now to help me
translate all of this Simlish everybody
join me in welcoming general manager
Lindsay Pearson and senior producer
Michael Duke for coming out guys so I'm
super excited I know you guys are super
excited yeah absolutely I've been with
the Sims a long time and this is one of
my favorite things to do is come out and
see all of you and tell you exciting
things absolutely and I mean it's gonna
be a big year for us it's actually we're
celebrating 20 years of making the Sims
this year yeah and Lindsay and I keep
debating it but I think this is gonna be
the best year yet I think it might be
well I mean really what we want to know
is what have you not for us come on tell
us everything of course well it is EA
play we couldn't come empty-handed so
we'll start with our big one first I'll
let you take that absolutely so we have
the next expansion pack for The Sims 4
Sims 4 island living let's check out
that trailer yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so cool and look we're in our
own little island parents can I'd you
same I didn't know what the reveals were
gonna be and I that is that you don't
know all this super weird
oh and obviously you know talking about
fashion there's a lot of Island fashion
they're one of the biggest things people
absolutely love um what can we be what
could be dressing up house what can we
look like absolutely you know to capture
that Island spirit we needed to have a
lot of new outfits and capture those not
exactly that but certainly those bright
colors like you're showing off there but
you know we really wanted to add a lot
of Island wear and that stuff you can
stay cool and when it's so hot it's true
yeah and we had to bring in a lot of new
fun colors and patterns but also hair's
accessories everything to deck out head
to toe to just chill and relax on this
beautiful island
I mean that's some amazing fashion right
there but what if yeah I'm getting a
little bit hot I'm not someone who likes
to dwell on a beach if you're not yeah
what if I want to go in the water what's
gonna be happening there so we're very
excited so for the first time in the
Sims for our Sims are going to be able
to walk right in to the open water yeah
an open water game play I mean like you
saw on the trailer she walks right in
our sins are gonna be able to do that
and you can snorkel in the water there's
swimming loading and there's also those
pretty awesome aqua zips yeah are in a
hurry you could get where you're going
inspired you guys to introduce this kind
of ocean gameplay this time yeah well
we've taken the Sims to a lot of
different worlds in a lot of different
places but we hadn't yet really played
with the idea of where the land and the
water meet and really bring you bring
you into an ocean environment which
seems like a great addition absolutely I
mean you know when I think of tropical
islands I'm thinking of you know like
palm trees ocean waves relaxing on the
beach so like tell me more about this
world what can I actually do in it yes
so the island of Solaria will have all
of those things and more it really is
the perfect place to unplug and enjoy
this natural feel so you can explore all
these little alcoves you can live closer
to the coast or you can live higher
higher up towards the hills or wait it's
there there's an active volcano I'm
sorry you just heard you say
me the dream of living on an island now
I'm not sure I really want to go there
it is a real island both islands are
formed by volcanoes picky yeah so we had
to put this active volcano in there now
you don't have to live next to it but
the riskier sims may choose to live near
oh oh yeah oh I don't I don't know how
that was gonna be when you touch
something that's really really hot
that's beautiful locale slightly
dangerous what other surprises are in
store on this island I mean I for one
want to know if I can befriend any kind
of cute animals don't meet the friends
well I mean it wouldn't be the Sims if
we didn't let you make friends with some
of the animals exactly um so in this
case the one we're really excited about
is the dolphin our art team animators
just blew away expectations like the
film team just going off to somewhere
hot they're so cute and you get to make
like a really nice friend with them and
maybe it'll do tricks for you or squirt
water in your face
absolutely well and then we also we
added a bunch of tropical fish to the
water team so we really wanted to get
those coral reefs around the island to
feel lush and fall and so that meant
more fish lay I mean I think I mean I
don't know we don't have fish like that
in the UK I mean we might do but the
water's so murky I've never seen them I
mean they must be what you put with the
chips I mean I I think the island exists
looks so relaxing obviously it's not
really about vacation it's also you know
it's it's about kind of working there as
well but like um what's kind of like the
feeling the vibe of the island gonna be
like you know I think it's one of those
things we talked a lot about in the team
is capturing what it would be like to
really live on that island it's not just
a place you vacation but we wanted this
to be a place that's home for yourselves
no tricks to be played on you well that
happens too well so there's lots to do
on the beach you saw Sun Tanning Sun
burning like building day hassles the
whole family can go out and play
together find seashells or the
mischievous Sims you know knock things
down well in aqua zips I
good there what are they called again
Aquos okay yeah it's there's a lot to
look at so you've got to take time to
really explore it all okay so obviously
we've established that Solaria is like a
great place there seems to kind of kick
back and you know what if my sims you
know they don't want to like I can't
personally lie on a beach for looking
about 30 minutes get ready bored what if
they want to get their hands dirty well
I'm very excited about a new thing that
we're introducing if your sims want a
new career to take care of this island
you can actually become a
conservationist and your job is gonna be
to keep this ecosystem looking beautiful
yeah I mean it's certainly one of the
big goals was a way for your Sims to
kind of care for their world
yeah and make it a better place yeah
obviously you know very relevant with
everything that's going on today in the
world and how everyone's kind of a lot
more kind of aware so was that kind of
what inspired you guys to bring that in
you know I think there's a few things
that really hit us I mean the first was
just it's something we all care about a
lot of us on the dev team worry about
the environment and what's going on but
we talked about the idea that this
islands this closed ecosystem and so
your actions and choices are gonna have
a lot more impact and so something new
we've added here and we're really
excited about is the island actually
changes over time so if you're taking
care of it it'll actually become more
lush you'll see more greenery brighter
beautiful flowers and there's Lindsay's
favorite part more butterflies bats but
also today happens to be World Oceans
Day which is amazing it's that's exactly
what we were talking about take care of
these ecosystems salon is really
beautiful you know you can kind of go
out there but like someone you want to
make a little bit of cash I mean you
know like barbecue meat I presume is
expensive I don't know but so how can we
make some extra samolians well when I
said I wanted to make this place you
live you've got to have a way to earn
some Somalia yeah I'm sure yeah Pia has
to end seven five money as much so we
added a couple like odd jobs and things
that you could kind of work on the hours
you wanted to write and so we've added
the ability to make fishing more of a
career and then also the lifeguard so
you can get your tan while you're
working if you want to spend more time
in the water you can be a dive
instructor there's a lot of different
ways to just pick up a job when you want
and earn a little bit of money yeah so
it's based on the important things as
well as it's not a vacation as you are
actually kind of living on this
Island obviously you know you have to
kind of be aware and know what's kind of
part of local culture because you're not
just there on holiday and you go in and
go out you're living there so what kind
of you know the side of the culture of
the island can we actually see within
right yeah this is a place that you live
and the locals are super friendly
actually and are gonna come and help you
out with all sorts of different things
as you tour the island like actually
like all the neighbors are really really
helpful and help ya can help you you
know like if a fire happens to break out
your neighbor might bust in and help you
put out there so but they also have
their own traditions their own sort of
activities that you might be able to
join in so you might stumble across
barbecue that they've started in town or
a little festival to sort of celebrate
things going on and you might even
stumble into a comma party sorry well a
cava policy what's a coffee so a cava is
a special Island drink that your sim can
learn how to make and share with their
friends on the island it's one of the
many delicacies you'll learn kind of
exploring life in Suwanee yeah I think
it's one of those things we talked about
was we wanted to have this island have a
little history to it just some sense of
feeling of some people have lived here a
long time and there are traditions that
are unique to this place the world of
Salani we kind of learn more about the
islands history like when we're there
how do we do that aside from you know
drinking kava that might be one
experience right but on top of that
something else the team was really
excited about adding as they're these
elementals around the island that are
kind of these spirits these ancients who
care a lot about Salani and you know
they want to see their world taken care
of and when you do good things they
might be really happy and pleased and if
you're bad the island I don't think they
may not stick in the tail yeah and we
also we added some new traits with this
pack that we wanted to really let if
your sims are super in touch with the
land or that's important to you you know
they can really get in touch with the
water or the land and unlock some new
behaviors okay so from what we've kind
of seen in all the videos it feels
really inspired by like Polynesian
culture so how do I kind of go about
kind of educating yourself to like bring
that into the game well every time we
make a world we want to learn a lot
about the influences that could go into
that place because it's not a particular
real place but it's inspired by real
places so short of flying there and
research
ourselves we reached out I'm sorry yeah
well he is a big global company so we
were able to reach out to a lot of our
friends and co-workers across the
company and say hey we're looking at
exploring a place inspired by this
culture yeah and could you share with us
some patterns or iconography or symbols
or even items that mean something to
this culture right so we can try and
create them in a way that feels rich and
feels authentic questions just like what
was iconic to you or what do you
remember when you think back to living
in that place right and some of our
specific like decor items came exactly
from those recommendations which is
really cool it's these nice touches that
I hope make it feel familiar while still
feeling like a new Sims world so not to
make light of all that because I think
that's fantastic I really feel like I've
been quite patient up into this point
and you haven't really mentioned it yet
mermaids mermaids mermaids tell us
everything here are mermaids yes so
mermaids are in the pack and I know lots
of players are gonna be wondering it is
a very fully feature to call it you can
take him into casts you can create and
style your mermaid lots of different
tales it's a lot of fun but also you
know the mermaids they can do a little
bit more obviously they're very in touch
with the ocean life mm-hmm so you know
I'd recommend your mermaid meet a
dolphin that might work out for you but
lastly the mermaids have some some
pretty cool powers that you might want
they're definitely worth exploring so I
can't wait for you guys to get your
hands on them so of course I would just
love to keep talking about mermaids but
no conversation about the Sims to be
complete without a chat about obviously
interior design so kind of what's new
for the architects about there yeah your
home's you furniture we saw some I
pretty sure we saw some houses on stilts
as well over the water right yeah so I
think you know first and foremost lounge
chairs we're gonna go to Islands we're
gonna live the beach life I'm sorry no
awkward sitting on the snow we've had to
bring the lounge chairs in but then also
a lot of that decor to really capture
that Polynesian feel right and so we
wanted to make sure there was that
clutter that felt authentic and let it
feel like this was home yeah and you can
go for this more sort of local style
Cabana
the beach or you can go for something a
little more high-end in modern we really
wanted you to feel like you could create
the like getaway of your dreams yeah for
sure and yeah I'm so 100% sold on the
houses over the water I'm a kind of
modern sort of house yeah for sure and
you might have noticed too she was able
to jump right off of that deck out into
the water which is the bridge like your
perfect little escape oh good I'm
feeling the diving into the water vibe I
can't wait to check out obviously the
new island living expansionpak and now
that I've got a feeling out that some of
you you know that you've got some more
exciting additional information as well
for so it's not just that you know you
have some more news in fact we're gonna
kick to somebody else for this
announcement alright no here's Joey
Graceffa
hello everyone and if you didn't know I
absolutely love the Sims and I'm so
excited to announce this upcoming
partnership with one of my favorite
games so this summer the Sims is
actually partnering with the amazing it
gets better project as part of this
partnership with it gets better since is
going to be releasing pride items in all
the Sims products in the next few months
there's going to be a variety of it gets
better and pride clothing in a Sims
FreePlay at the zoo's mobile app in Sims
4 there's even a gender-neutral bathroom
in Sims 4 along with a bunch of other
items to show off your pride thanks so
much for letting me share this news with
everyone now go out and enjoy your EA
play that's so cool to see that's really
really cool to see and thanks so much to
Joey for showing for that I mean what a
great partnership as well to be
announcing of course because it's it's
you know it's Pride Month it's Pride
Week here in Los Angeles how are you
guys going about kind of supporting that
great cause well The Sims has always
been a game about being inclusive and
the self-expression of creating yourself
and people you know and telling your own
story so this is a wonderful opportunity
to bring new content in the game to
celebrate that definitely and I think
also people don't realize how important
it is sometimes you know when you're
kind of growing up and you're figuring
out who you are you're discovering what
kind of person you are and just growing
you know about your sexuality and being
able to kind of sort of roleplay within
games is a really really safe place to
do that so you know
you guys have been doing it pretty much
from the start way before everyone else
so it's really great I mean it's not
great to see so so great yeah well it's
something we're very proud of and having
been with the game a long time it's
something that keeps making me excited
about being able to do more yeah I love
when we get to do stuff like that you
know it just it makes what we do feel so
much more powerful and meaningful and
you know I just I always be getting to
tell people that I work on this game
amazing stuff you know and also when we
get to hear from our community about the
experiences they've had or how the game
helped them get through a tough time in
their life or realize something about
themselves it's just that stuff really
keeps us going as develop our --fill
gaming is and how much it can really
kind of affect and change you as a
person and show you stuff it's um it's
amazing so when can we get our hands on
it yeah so Joey mentioned briefly but
it's starting June 18th
the pride content will come to the Sims
4 and then it will start rolling out
over the Sims mobile and the Sims
FreePlay a little bit later so keep an
eye out for that absolutely I mean it
that's great but I mean I think you've
actually got him this is such a
ridiculous and outlays backed about
right what else you've got something
else that you want to announce in the
summer we actually had I think two more
things we wanted to I'm gonna I'm gonna
let Lindsey talk about this all right so
first of all earlier this year we
announced our partnership with mosquito
by releasing a real world capsule
collection of looks inspired by the Sims
I see some of them and I'm very excited
we had a hoodie that was actually put
into all of our Sims games so later this
summer
we're gonna be bringing that fashion and
more to the sims for mosquito stuff pack
crazy yes so not only are we gonna be
looking pretty pretty special but what
if we want to kind of go and strut our
stuff somewhere else and like really
show off the outfits that we've got well
so I think one of the things that I'm
most excited about in this stuff pack is
for the first time we're actually gonna
add a career as part of a stuff bag so
we've decided the perfect career for
this pack okay a part-time job is a
freelance fashion photographer so you
can capture all those amazing looks yes
can now rock that's so me yeah yes it's
gonna be fun that looks really good I'm
excited
Wow we've covered so much so far a new
expansion a new partnership a new stuff
back but we're not done yet phone oh no
we're not Mike Enzi brought one more big
surprise for all of you guys yes I know
you're all hoping so we thought maybe we
could tell you which game pack we had in
mind oh I don't know I I think maybe we
could conjure up something all right
Mike I'll let you spell it out for them
the next game pack for the sims 4 is
realm of magic that's amazing
I mean why don't we gonna get more info
on this I mean aside from the fact that
you just told us just now and like you
ready just talk this yes so we will tell
you more about the game pack later this
year so you'll have to wait a little
more but it is coming this fall it is
coming this fall yeah wow I can't wait
these guys clearly can't wait community
members asking yeah so big thank you to
Lindsey and Michael and thank you so
much for showing us what's next in the
sims 4 so let's just quickly recap this
because there's a few things to get
through in its heart and you might have
forgotten so the island living reveal
trailer is live now the expansion is
playable here at EA play and you can
play it at home soon but it gets better
Fri content starts rolling out and in a
few weeks
oh sorry in a few weeks and the racino
stuff back comes out later this summer
so don't forget to check out all the
Sims social channels for even more info
and launch dates so that's it for the
sims it's been an exciting day here with
so so much news I can't wait to join the
fan fest and get my hands on the island
living expansion packs so from all of us
here goodbye we'll see you later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]